[Music]
what you'll learn is that the foundation
of everything you do in search engine
optimization is based in keywords you
see when you understand the motive and
the intent of the searcher it helps you
understand what they need the words in
the phrases they use and how you can
utilize those words on your website in
order to be found when they are trying
to solve a problem or find information
you can then take those words make your
website your content and your overall
marketing much more relevant and visible
because you understand the searcher the
objectives of this module as I want you
to see the purposes of keywords how
people search the keyword search trends
and buying cycles and how they affect
the words people use also how a search
path when someone is intent on solving a
problem and how that branches into
additional key word areas and also what
we can learn from keyword research I
also want you to see how these words are
so connected to the searcher and their
intent now the foundation of keyword
research as I've alluded to before it is
a direct line into the mind of the
searcher it's direct information that
people type into search engines to find
information that they need right now you
see as there is words go into the search
engine that republished in keyword
research tools so that we can find what
people were looking for understand the
words they use in the phrases that they
add we can get some hints as to their
motivations and what do they need how do
they associate our brand name with other
words or what keywords do they associate
together
you see keywords are so essential most
of the time when I start working with a
new business I find that they use their
own words their own terminology on the
website
they've never researched to see what do
their customers use as a word instead
they are focused on their company and
the way they've always done it and so
those words are much more internalized
and internally focused keyword research
helps us take that focus off of our own
internal methodology of naming things or
using words that might just be native to
our company or to our industry
keyword research helps us understand
what do searchers or customers call
these things and what words do they use
when they're searching for them that's
how we understand the mind of the
searcher so this is the foundation of
search engine optimization which
branches into almost every other digital
marketing channel you see we understand
word associations what words people will
use and how they arrange them when they
search for them how they associate a
brand also directions references
questions locations all types of other
words that people will add into the
queries that we can learn from and not
only does it help us in terms of
optimization it helps us understand the
big picture of what people need so we
can also utilize this in content
development because our searchers are
giving us ideas of the types of
information that they want to see so we
can develop that content to answer those
questions keywords are ultimately ideas
the more we listen to our customer the
more benefit we'll get from this
research in fact when I am training
people to work in search engine
optimization the main area of focus is
keyword research I find that the better
people are able to research and
understand the words that people use
the patterns the frequencies the
associations the placements the more an
optimizer understands the words the
easier everything else is because they
can leverage that in two different areas
of marketing and it becomes second
nature to understand what the customer
wants
so initially keyword research is where
we start pulling together all the words
within the industry that people are
using I typically will start with the
big picture word the big picture phrase
of what is this business or what is this
industry about what is the product what
does it do I'm looking for my big
picture words in other words if someone
asked you what your company does your
answer would be the first thing that I
would start looking for and start
looking for associated words terms and
related words to that I would then start
looking at product categories or
business categories and look to see what
is specific to your business and how are
people searching for that this is where
I'll start to develop some catalogs or
categories of words and start to group
them accordingly I would also look at
longtail words these are the four or
five or six word phrases that people use
to describe exactly what they want I'll
go into more about that later I also
want to look at your brand name and how
people search for your brand name and
the types of words they associate it
with really I'm looking for people
places and things that are related to
those terms I want to know all the other
associations that they make then I want
to try and put everything in the context
of a buying cycle what are the initial
words people would search on when they
know they have a need what would be the
big overriding search term and then as
people learn about your industry or
business how would they then use
additional words to focus their search
on more specific information that's the
buying cycle
how do people
start to search how do they acquire more
information how do they compare multiple
results and how do they make that final
decision I also want to understand the
questions that searchers are asking such
as how do I do this or where do I find
we can even go back to the four micro
moment questions and consider how that's
relevant to your industry and then I
want to look at some secondary phrases
those that are extremely pinpointed
those that are maybe related but not
specific or even more broad based terms
just to keep an idea of how people
search now I talked about the buying
cycle and here's an example of how it
works that people search when they have
an interest this is the micro moment
this is when they put action to
inspiration they know they have a need
and so they search and typically this is
a very broad term they're getting a
sense of what's out there and then they
start to gather information so this
could be different brand names different
product types different areas of
interest but they're broadening their
scope to find out who all can satisfy
this problem who all can provide an
answer and so they're developing
research and they're adding more words
to their search phrase in order to
expand who they're looking at and the
information they're receiving then they
define the problem and start to exclude
vendors and finally they're ready to
commit now that commitment may be done
through the search engine where they
type in specifically this is what I want
and see who comes up in the results
ideally through a good program of search
engine optimization you have visibility
in the interest when people first search
you have visibility when people are
gathering information you have
visibility at the final stage when
people are ready to commit people's
search terms change throughout the
buying cycle as they acquire
more information and decide what is that
they really want another example of this
is what I call the search path this is
extremely important in terms of I've
seen this done very well in travel
marketing where people know that they
want to go to a specific destination for
a holiday that's the concept well once
you've decided where you want to go then
you have to look at transportation to
get there you have to look at all the
alternatives that are available maybe
you have to consider where exactly
you're going to stay you see this is
where searching for one concept branches
then into multiple concepts
it creates secondary searches and then
it gets to what I call the practical
level which is once you're there how do
you know where you're going to eat we're
going to shop what you're going to see
and so there you're looking at reviews
you're looking at local search features
and then looking at very specific
searches Travel is very accommodating to
this type of search path because making
one search leads to multiple searches
which then leads to searching to enhance
your activities once you're there one
search leads to multiple searches and
keyword research helps us to understand
how people are moving through the search
path and how they are utilizing the
information to make decisions ultimately
what we are doing with keywords is
connecting to the customer really we're
utilizing a search engine to connect to
a human we're trying to get to the
bottom level of what people want intent
and when we discover what people want we
can reflect that terminology those
concepts and those words on our website
now I'm going to show you from a popular
keyword research tool called word
tracker there are many keyword research
tools and I'll share a number of them
with you at the end they all have a
primary function and so what I'm going
to show you in this module
is consistent across a vast majority of
keyword research tools the first thing
you need to do is type an initial
keyword this is where you typically will
start with a primary industry keyword if
someone asks what you do or what you
sell this is where you type it in this
is I usually like to start very general
so that you will get the most amount of
keywords and keyword variations so this
is where you start by typing your
initial keyword the next column in this
case is the time period now this can be
a monthly average maybe an annual
average or some will even break down to
a weekly I usually go with the monthly
average and please remember that once we
start talking about counts and averages
these are not very accurate I'll explain
that later as we go on in keyword
research the next tab is global or
regional if you're looking for something
specific to your country or to your
region this is where you select I don't
always use global because it's not
always relevant especially if you have a
language specific search that you're
working on or if it's a country based
company you want to restrict your search
to that area otherwise the results of
your keyword research may be skewed by
including searches that aren't relevant
or from areas that you don't market to
once you've added in your keyword the
time frame and the region then you hit
search and the keyword research tool
will go out and start building a list of
all the related keywords now my keyword
choice here was digital marketing I
wanted to look and see what word tracker
would return for the keywords digital
marketing as you can see there are
nearly 4,000 keyword suggestions what
that means is that there are almost
4,000 variations of the phrase digital
marketing
using those terms that's kind of
exciting that means that there are
thousands of ways that people are
searching for digital marketing so that
should tell you right away that not all
of them are going to be relevant to you
or your business and so we need to start
looking at the words in order to figure
out which ones are relevant to what we
want and which ones are not so the first
thing you'll notice is just the list of
keywords those are the keyword
suggestions that's the list of keywords
returned based on your search the next
column shows the estimated number of
searches per month this is the
popularity index now as you can see at
the top of the list digital marketing by
itself receives about 2700 searches per
month just under that digital marketing
service receives about 270 searches per
month now regardless of the keyword tool
these numbers are not exact in fact it
would be dangerous for you to consider
them to be exact what we're looking at
here is just a sense of the ratio of how
much more certain words are more popular
than others
how much certain words are searched more
than others well go into more detail on
this but suffice it here we're not
looking at the hard numbers we're just
getting a sense of which are more
popular than others next is how many
other sites in this catalog as they go
out and look at different sites in the
search engine results how many other
keywords are utilizing the keyword
digital marketing in their page title
and a text link this tells you how many
other websites are actively optimizing
for these words by putting it in the
page title and a text link those are two
vital page elements and so if someone is
using them
it's a good indicator that it's going to
be a high competition now the next
column is the competition this tells you
an index number of the competitive sites
utilizing the same keywords and so if
it's a high number that means there's
high competition
for example as we can see the very top
digital marketing almost 3000 searches
and also word tracker is telling us that
there are over 36,000 websites that are
using the word digital marketing in
their page title and linking so that's a
high competition number and that's also
referenced in the competition column by
a competition index of 27 now if you'll
notice underneath there is a keyword
digital marketing reports
that's only has a popularity of about
244 per month but also there's zero
competition for that and so it's got a
zero in the index meaning there's not a
lot of competition the next column is
the Kei and this is the keyword
effectiveness index this is what most
keyword tools have consistent among them
and that is an index number to let you
know the effectiveness of the
competition for this keyword and so the
word digital marketing what it is doing
is taking the amount of searches perform
monthly comparing it to the amount of
competitive websites and then gives you
an index number now the index here is 58
which is not too bad the main reason why
is because there is so much competition
however that's balanced out by the
amount to demand the next result has a
lot less competition it has a
competition index of six but according
to the keyword effectiveness index the
effectiveness is 76 that's because even
though there's less competition there's
less demand and so it will be harder to
to gain rankings for keyword that's less
in demand and less competition however
that competition is significant
so the Kei provides you a quick index as
to the effectiveness of the competition
and what you should look for in terms of
just setting a proper view of your
expectations for that keyword it
typically takes a while especially if
you're a brand new site to gain rankings
so the Kei will provide you that
long-term view of what you should expect
and one of the things I really like in
keyword tools are the keyword trends you
see most keywords do not have a
consistent search pattern throughout the
year it changes month by month and
depending upon your industry or your
business or what products you sell you
may see radical shifts from one month to
the next so I always like to know this
index because I want to know when the
popularity trend is when do most people
search for this word that helps me plan
my content and my SEO accordingly the
next feature is the SERP preview just
showing you that for the word digital
marketing which sites typically show up
in the top 10 and that way you can get a
sense of the competition you'll be up
against for different keywords the nice
thing here is it's all contained in one
dashboard you can click on a very
specific keyword see the annual trend
and then also the top 10 results for
that keyword that is a world of
information that lets you know
competitively what you're up against
when researching keywords now in case
you're wondering here's a list of some
of the keyword research tools that are
used in the industry I was using word
tracker you can also use Google Adwords
sem rush Raven tools Moz link decks and
jacksie are just a few of the numerous
keyword
tools available to you but they all have
about the same level of functionality
some more than others and some allow
more site management than others it's
really going to come down to what fits
you your business and your budget in
terms of developing your keyword
research initiative this is one expense
that you should plan for having a good
keyword research tool is going to be
critical to your effectiveness in search
engine optimization a great keyword
research tool will help you be a great
optimizer and so this is an investment
that should be made most of them have an
annual or monthly payment scheme and so
you can do whatever fits your budget but
find one that enables you to research
and catalog your keywords hey once you
become an expert in digital marketing
then subscribe to the simply learned
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn up and get certified in
digital marketing click here